all right well this is it we're getting
started good and proper we're on our way
to pick up the u-haul and then Park it
and then we've got a crew meeting this
evening where most of the crew most of
the crew will be there and we're just
gonna just gonna be sort of an
orientation give everybody an overview
of what the next two days are gonna look
like and and then it's one more sleeps
[Music]
one more sleeps and then
and this starts
[Music]
all right it's Wednesday morning I'm
sitting here outside a real fabrication
just waiting for people show up so we
can load up the set into the truck and
then take it on up to the warehouse
how are we doing this boy Kara pretty
good not a lot of sleep but
we got
[Music]
from because Hans gonna build
kara what are we looking at
[Music]
95% done
nine-thirty
we've been added since nine hand yeah
so we're tired we're exhaustive and we
got an early morning so but that's it
for tonight yeah tomorrow shoot day
shoot day the rubber hits the road are
you nervous
I wasn't until right now now I'm
terrified I'm a little scared not
because I don't think we're gonna fail
I'm scared that we're gonna make
something absolutely
ultimately we will have a few
problem-solving
we have an awesome
it's excited yeah
[Music]
it's happened so literally think so far
guys
from this point
[Music]
yes
that's right dog yeah t-bone a Westside
forever what are you coming yeah we're
just once
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
I'm feeling good
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh God I've got the Twitter response
okay so I just posted you know
[Music]
between shots the skull does the skull
have a name MacArthur
[Music]
great said on paper
sure
[Music]
variations on stone sword
Oh God
[Music]
[Applause]
it's been a long day but it's been a
good day you've got a lot of good stuff
we got great actors we got a great crew
it's been it's been fun
I'm tired and there's still a whole
bunch there's still a whole bunch more
to go but yeah now we're getting there
well you see what I do all right
so the session chorus full break at
every period
[Music]
yeah pull break every period a little
bit aggressive like just just kind of
you know metal where this circle is not
having high no you know it was high
because
[Music]
we are rolling so just sleep with
high-five
[Music]
you